times over
eighth week is generally a winding down
period in Oxford you have the last set
of classes you have the last set of
lectures you generally try and make the
most of being around your friends and do
some social stuff before you head back
home but being fourth year student it's
a little bit different for me because my
masters projects draft is doing next the
end of next week
so I need to stick around for at least
another week just to make sure that
that's handled improperly and it's got
to the point now we're on to actual
science in the master's project so I
talked about this in a previous video
about what my project is about but
basically it comes down to trying to fit
this model to Glassboro data and we
found that there's a it seems to be a
simple relationship between how close
together your points are and how far
into the future you can make predictions
which is kind of cool but being eighth
week most of this week is focused on
trying - of your friends and making most
the opportunities available and occifer
before we are hasta came back home so
loads of different things happen in
eighth week for one thing the eternally
publications of the oxymoron and the
Peter farm are published those are
they're both comedy rags basically
they're both comedy magazines that are
published the oxymoron on the university
wide scale PETA filed just with Vincent
Peters my favorite thing in the Peter
father's time I think is philosophy
library in existential crisis terrific
things were recounted by those present
at the library on Thursday one student
claimed to have spent five hours trying
to decide whether to write his essay in
Times New Roman or Calibri before
concluding that meaning was an arbitrary
social construct I'm proceeding to
explain this in wingdings all the
oxymorons are both past and present are
actually available on their website
which I will link to in the description
following on for my successors thing
Brian may mean Ian last week this week I
went to see a kind of childhood hero of
mine I guess I've got Bray meters I
watched all of his documentaries and I
was a kid so I actually got to meet him
was amazing so he was talking about the
solo expedition that he did to Canada
and he spent about a week just canoeing
on his own through the lakes and they're
talking about the practicalities of
doing a solo expedition and how amazing
it is
then on Friday really the end end of
term two things happened I remember
instant litres of the middle culinary or
the MCR and the JCR the genie economy
because I'm a fourth-year student so I'm
kind of doing my graduate year but I'm
also I haven't graduated so I benefit
from being
to go to events put on by the MCA and
the JCR and on Friday the jacket the MC
I was putting on a cocktail meeting so
they were doing cocktails for free we
have free nibbles loads of people round
in the mci it was just a chance to
mingle catch up with friends they hadn't
seen for awhile because we're all doing
lastest projects that I even and try and
meet a few new people as well then
immediately after that went to the JCR
for the last pop of the term now because
finalists don't really have time to go
to bops
in the last term well certainly the end
of the last time this was the finalists
spot so we got to decide on a theme and
bipolar was decided that the theme
should be a tease so lots of big hair
what's another jacket now during the pop
I was thinking but it's not in the
series of introducing specifically
Oxford things in the past we factor both
linear Schmeling I haven't covered one
really important part of my Oxford life
and in fact the college's the Oxford
life now sir Peter's College has been
voted as having the best bar in the
university and it has also invited as
having the best college drinks and
Peters has the crosskeys now cost five
pounds and it's the typical pop fair
pour more our lovely bar treasurer will
explain what goes into them and make you
up into this crosskeys goes to shots of
Apple sours one shot of Goldschlager two
shots of vodka watch avocado lemon aid
lame-ass and frankly it's job a drink to
get the job done two of those and you're
good to go out now Jamie you ask me a
question and your audience a question
but I've been thinking an awful lot
about over the course of the past year
and you asked what is the ultimate goal
in life what makes me happy I've come to
the conclusion that I basically align
myself with utilitarianism so this idea
that increasing the total amount of
happiness other people feel is what
makes me happiest the two things which I
enjoy the most in life are learning new
things and teaching teaching other
people new things which is why I want to
become a university lecturer because I
get to combine the two things seem that
ignition
when they really understand it for the
first time seeing that in 30 different
people's faces you know that you've made
their lives that bit richer you made
them that bit happier by doing that and
to me that's the the greatest pursuit of
all I want other people to be happy and
in doing that that makes
be happy but then this begs the question
if I'm making other people happy
chilly I'm I'm doing that only to make
me happy not for the purpose of making
them happy so rather than being
utilitarian this that not make me head
nest I don't know very much about
philosophy and I'd like to learn more
maybe we should do a video each
explaining about things like this you
could expend a bit of philosophy and I
could explain a bit of physics so that's
it look for the years over I can finally
rest and just wish I could another thing
that I forget